I saw you had Jim Carrey on for an
entire episode you broke format yeah
well when you get a Jim Carrey you got
to Jim Carrey actually said I want to
come on and I'll do the panel I'll do
that with everybody because he's super
cool but the more we talked about it the
more I thought it's just he's too much
the focus he's too big a deal
yeah and he's someone I never get to
talk to or see I talked to Murphy a
couple years when I see him at when you
were coming up and stand-up comedy were
you around when Jim Carrey was doing
stand-up comedy in other words did you
guys run into each other
Jim was on living color but I was just
doing stand-up and I lost a job too in
living I was up for that why I didn't
even know about that crazy the one white
guy on in the color I auditioned a bunch
of times a bunch of times in fact you
told the story which I didn't know that
you had booked two weeks in Hawaii for
stand-up yes which for a young comic
yeah that's great because he'd get a
nice little vacation out of that in nice
weather and whatever goes on and paid
yeah and paid and and so they called you
up and said listen we want you for in
living color well yeah well they said
you know you're gonna audition I wasn't
really I was a name no nothing but I was
a comic at the improv and I was doing
pretty good as far as I was 20 you know
21 looked younger than that
did you we did you know you were up
against Jim Carrey oh I would have
[ __ ] quit of course but I mean Jim
Carrey wasn't a name at that point at
all I mean nobody had ever true you know
once I saw what he did I was like oh how
do you do that when you when you were
young and you would audition for stuff
and if you don't get it do you then
watch in living color and go that's the
[ __ ] guy who got it
well I always use it it's going so much
[ __ ] better this guy yeah we see Jim
Carrey go goddamn did they make the
right call yeah I mean I don't even know
what I was doing these others I can
improv kind of but I can't be like you
know get Dana Carvey get these people
that are so good at that
you know I that wasn't like my thing I
was just going to auditions and I
wouldn't even ask for therefore they go
did you read the script I go I don't
know I can't I won't tell me what to do
I read the first two auditions and then
the rest of the year they're coming so
fast you just show up
did Jim know you were up for that the
part or you know for that show or they
didn't know you got to tell them well I
told him on the show
yeah oh we laugh and then yeah it was
funny to him when he had the when I but
I was around when he had that run of Ace
Ventura into the mask into dumb and
Dumberer I'm like I don't I mean maybe
Sandler but there's no one has a run
that hard
no one monsters